you're like a [ __ ] what's the
opposite of a juggernaut I don't know
like a table man evil dude table that
doesn't go anywhere for even look at
room table that doesn't go anywhere for
years that a family doesn't even use
they just put stuff on dude your files
that's what you are dude and I are they
eat in front of the TV and all that [ __ ]
and they never use that that dining room
table man so your mouth is too wet
[ __ ] dining room table Kalen on it
you're lit your mouth gets all wet when
you get this wet back to it it gets
[ __ ] wet my mouth is like a [ __ ]
dude it's so great do when you go to
kiss a girl what do you would you ever
say anything before you do it like yep
when you win your first time you're
gonna kiss a girl Yeah right
mm-hmm and you're about to go in yep
what are you so so you're the end of the
date you having a great time yeah and
she wants you to kiss her you maybe she
doesn't you don't know yep
what do you do I go like this I'm a
Republican why do you say that you might
be able to throw her off
I'm not even a Republican right I just
go I'm a Republican that's how you kiss
dude yup dude that's not good meat but
you're making your lips all puckered up
I know you're open they go for volume
and then I go and then I meet their lips
like that and then I use my lips to own
their lips like that and then I stick
that's how I do and then that comes up
[ __ ] Republican and I'm not even a
republican but I make girls Republicans
do now when you when you go downtown
yeah do you ever do that
are you afraid of you talking about a
sideways burger no that bleeds don't
tell me you say that to her I say hey
hey come on be romantic in your voice
you would say I say hey baby yeah make
your burger sideways what does that mean
make your burger sideways cuz if they're
like this they're children but then they
go like this Cyrus what
[ __ ] meat did I meet the [ __ ]
lifted the thing Oh same thing sideways
better okay then it's time to actually
have sex yeah and do it uh-huh what do
you say that well what's her name Mandy
Mandy now let's say her name is Penelope
Penelope
okay so first time having sex I'm doing
it right before I haven't put it in
there yet no but I don't say much I just
like kiss and I make it nice and I
[ __ ] you know I make sure to like look
at him and use a lot of eye contact and
yeah and then right before I climax
what's her name okay I go like this
before I go like this it's a gift